The joe rogan experience fucking 16 hours to remote audio book.
I was like,
oh my God,
I cannot read out loud to save my life.
16 hours.
How many hours is the actual audio book?
Three.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
I am the worst out loud reader and for like the first two chapters get mad if
you fuck it up.
Yeah.
The guy who asked me like are the first,
first chapter.
He's like,
hey man,
do you need glasses?
I was like,
no,
I just,
I'm not that good at it.
And I was like,
I'll do it drunk.
Everyone wants to hear me do a drunk,
you can't fucking read drunk.
So then I described that day,
that day is all you supposed to had to go back and Redo it.
And then,
and then I was also like,
like I'd read a passage and then I go on and be like,
I'm like,
and then I'd expound on what I just read and kind of was like an,
I was like a podcast and that was fucking horrible cause that took like forever.
And so that finally the guys like,
just fucking read it.
So I'll just read it towards the end,
but it gets better.
I think you'd be better if you just read it and if you fucked up,
just comment on the fact that you fucked that word up and just keep going on
like that way people would,
they would get,
they'd get the book,
the whole book,
but they'd also get like experience of you reading the book.
Like you separating yourself from the book while you're at it.
Oh yeah.
I mean they,
I don't know what it's going to sound like but cause I,
I did acknowledge it.
I did one,
I did fuck up cause I'm a comic so I would work the piece as I was like if I was
on stage.
And did they keep that in or do they edit that stuff?
They kept s I think they kept some of it in but they couldn't have kept all of
it in.
That's so weird though that they decide what gets left in and what comes out.
This whole to this whole book writing process has been vulnerable as fucked
because you,
you really let go of it because it's an entirely different industry.
Yeah.
I didn't,
I passed,
I had a book deal.
I was writing the book and they were still giving these old wacky fucking notes.
Just advice on like how I should talk about things,
what I should describe and how I was like,
we're not,
this is not happening.
You know,
you're not involved in the creative process.
I gave them their money back.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Like they wanted me to essentially write my act down on paper and sell it as a
book and they're like,
well George Carlin did it and Jerry Seinfeld did it.
I was like,
ah,
that's nice.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm not doing that.
I write different than I do stand up.
It's two different things.
Like you can write when you're writing,
like just writing.
There's a way that you can express yourself that's unavailable if you're
talking,
you know,
it's,
it's why you,
the dragon dictate didn't work for me cause you'd talk it into this dragon
dictate and it would put it right into the computer,
like print it.
But it didn't work for me because it sounded spoken like it sounded like and,
and,
and a couple like,
and one of the hard things for me was I,
I did that same thing where they wanted to,
all the stories I had told on stage or on podcasts,
I was like,
I can't,
I can't do that.
I can't just fill it up with that.
Yeah.
They want the stuff that they think they're going to sell.
It's not a,
an artistic thing.
It's like,
guess what dummy?
The same person that told those funny stories.
I can tell you other funny stories,
like we're not running out of funny stories here.
It's really fascinating.
And,
and their stories,
I had to put in the book,
I had to put the machine in.
I can't not write that in there.
And there's a lot of,
there's like the Will Smith Story.
I had to put it in,
but then I wanted to do this several polls.
One I wanted to do one where I met Ralph Sampson and when I was a kid I was
Ralph Sampson.
Um,
he was a basketball player and I was,
I went to school at,
I went to,
I was like in eighth grade I decided I really wanted to be a basketball player.
And so I went to Villanova basketball camp and Ralph Sampson came to speak.
And like the first night I got a concussion and the two best basketball players
got pulled out for drinking.
So the next day I had to sit out with the two best possible players and everyone
thought we drank together.
So now all of a sudden I'm 15,
14 and everyone thinks I'm cool because I'm parting with the 18 year olds.
So Ralph Sampson,
coms,
I thought this define me.
Ralph Sampson comes up to give a speech.
He's like,
I'm here to talk to you about two things there.
5,000 kids on the gym floor.
He said,
we were talking about basketball and we're talking about discipline first let's
talk about discipline.
Who in here?
Parties.
And I was under the impression we were all gonna put our hands up,
but I was the only fucking person,
I just want to shrink.
And he was like,
Oh one person,
5,000 kids,
no one raise her fucking hand.
He's like,
how do you party?
I was fucking 13 I know how to,
I didn't,
I never partied in my life.
So all I said was hardy and he fucking lost it.
And 5,000 kids are slapping the gym floor.
Like,
Oh shit,
we're going to make an example out of you.
Party animal.
He's lost the room.
So he brings me up front to the in front of all the kids and he makes me stand
up and he puts a basketball behind my legs like this and then one on my arms
like this.
And he's like,
we party hardy.
What?
We're going to party hardy today.
So I'm standing like this for his whole fucking hour speech with basketball here
and there.
And he's like,
and he keeps coming back to me.
And by the way,
I'm so in my head that I'm,
I'm have social anxiety disorder but I'm in front of everyone and I'm like being
made fun of being mocked that I wasn't listening to his question.
Somebody is like,
you think you'll ever party again?
I just said yeah and the fucking place went bananas.
They're like,
oh.
And he's like,
how do you party hardy?
I was like,
and I didn't know the answer.
I just was like with two hands,
fucking people are losing.
You think you'd do marijuana and now I'm killing.
I'm like I'll get to in college and these kids,
I left that gym and everyone wanted to talk to me.
Everyone's like party animal.
What are you doing and that you're still holding the basketball between your
legs the whole fucking time.
Cracking jokes while I'm cracking jokes.
And how long did you hold the basketball?
An hour.
That's a long time by my cousin ape.
I almost brought him here to there.
I should have,
I didn't even think about it.
My cousin aid was there at the camp even cause he's from Philly.
I didn't know anyone.
My cousin,
he was like,
I didn't even,
I didn't know you partied.
I go,
I don't,
I just thought we'd all put our fucking hands off.
He's like,
no,
why would you put your hands up if you don't party?
I was like,
I want it to be cool.
So yeah,
so like so now and then everyone would come up and they'd be like,
party animal,
you partying harder than I'd be like,
yeah.
But then I became cool at that camp and then I have friends and so I wrote that
story is a little longer and I gave to them,
I go,
this is the best story.
This defines me.
And they're like,
oh,
I'm out.
Really?
That's hilarious.
So it's all partying stories,
but it's like that's a hilarious story.
Don't thanks so nutty that this could have possibly sent you on a path when you
were that young.
You know,
13 years old.
I just,
I,
and it's all just wanting to be accepted.
I remember.
Did you ever have one of those moments where you'd go somewhere and you didn't
know anybody but you felt like everyone fucking grew up together?
Yeah,
that's a weird feeling.
I felt like that a lot as a kid.
Yeah.
But I thought that that define me because then I became the,
I became the party animal but kind of lived up to whatever.
By the way,
I went to high school the very next year.
It didn't know anyone,
so I'm sure that kind of,
I was like,
well it worked in Villanova.
So yeah,
there's definitely different personality that develops when kids have to move to
right.
If they move from one spot to another spot and move more than once they develop
this.
Like it's this weird newcomer personality,
you know,
in every romantic kids movie,
the rebel that moved into town,
the new kid that you don't know if any think he smoked cigarettes and fucking
twilight style movie or even like karate kid.
Didn't he like move into some new town dude,
crazy kid.
I was fucking,
the day karate kid came out,
it was my first day of tennis camp.
And so,
so I go,
I gotta fucking can't believe I didn't write about this.
This I didn't mean no anyone.
I know anyone.
So then the,
these all the La Veranda camp,
I started meeting the cool kids and they were like,
hey man,
what are you doing today?
I was like,
nothing.
And then if you want to go see karate kid and I didn't know anything about it
and I was like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that'd be cool.
So like cool,
meet us at mission bell.
That's where this place was.
My Mom's late picking me off.
We're late doing everything.
She drops me off to the movie late and I go in and the movie's already started
at,
can't find any of the kids,
but I already bought the ticket and I already have popcorn and a drink and I'm
like,
fuck.
So I just go down and I sit down.
I've never seen a movie by myself that time and I just sit down and I keep
looking for him,
but I can't fucking find them.
But then the movie starts and it's a great fucking movie and it's a movie about
a loner kid like myself that doesn't know anyone and he's trying to break into
the new group,
just like I was doing a tennis camp and I really get involved in it.
I get so involved with the movie that when he does the fucking crane kick and
kicks the guy,
I start bawling,
fucking crying,
thinking I'm Danielson.
I'm Dan in my head,
I'm like,
I feel like Daniel son,
the houselights come up and the fucking kids that were had wanted me to meet,
we're sitting directly like two rows in front of me and I heard you weeping,
heard me crying,
and I'm weeping.
Like,
wow,
bing,
like a fucking 10 year old cry.
Like if you were 10,
how'd that work out?
Uh,
they turn around and they saw me crying and there were about to make fun of me.
And they're like,
oh,
you got us,
you got,
we thought you were crying and you fucking with us.
He was sitting behind us the whole time.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
And I fucking walked out that movie.
I still to this day,
so you,
you had to fake that.
You weren't crying to fake that I wasn't crying and then we all hung out in
there.
Like,
you can just do that,
make yourself cry.
And I was like,
yeah,
okay.